Губернатор Миколаївщини Олексій Савченко
закликає містян свідомо боротися з корупцією.
У відповідь чує дедалі більше звинувачень у корупції
на свою адресу.
Після самогубства колишнього учасника АТО,
військового льотчика Владислава Волошина,
який виконував обов'язки директора місцевого аеропорту,
громадські активісти вимагають відставки губернатора.
Довести Владислава Волошина до самогубства
міг тиск обладміністрації для прикриття її незаконних оборудок
з ремонтом будівлі аеропорту, переконаний журналіст Андрій Лохматов.
Для нього несення відповідальності за це все
було б ганьбою, гірше за смерть.
У своєму розслідуванні журналіст наводить факти про те,
що ремонт аеровокзалу зробили за усною домовленістю
між обласною владою та підрядником без жодних тендерів чи проектів.
Підрядник - "Житлопромбуд-8" - витратив на це власні кошти,
імовірно, 40 мільйонів гривень. Щоб узаконити ремонт,
аеропорт оголосив тендер, утім,
виграла його інша фірма з Києва. Тож обласна влада
видає розпорядження скасувати тендер
і шукає варіанти, як розрахуватися з підрядником.
Як я зрозумів, вонизнайшли найганебніший вихід:
просто взяти акти виконаних робіт від цього підрядника
і підсунути Волошину, щоб він їх підписав.
А це означає, що після цього повинна пройти проплата,
але ніяких законних підстав для цього не може бути.
Ні, він не підписав.
Звинувачення на свою адресу губернатор Савченко відкидає.
Місцеві активісти переконані:
трагедії з  Владиславом Волошиним можна було уникнути,
якби правоохоронці взялися за справу ще в січні,
коли журналіст оприлюднив своє розслідування.
Або наприкінці лютого, коли місцевий активіст Євген Воловой
подав петицію в Адміністрацію президента
з вимогою відставки губернатора.
Тепер активіст сподівається на всебічне і незалежне
розслідування щодо всіх причетних
до проекту відновлення аеропорту.
Щонайменше ці люди на період розслідування
мають подати в відставку або самі, або за проханням зверху.
Розслідування не повинні проводити "друзі губернатора" тут, на місці.
А більш компетентні органи, мабуть,із Києва.
І,як мінімум, маєвзятиучастьуцьомуНАБУ.
Директор Центру антикорупційних досліджень
Денис Барашковський переконаний:
треба створити слідчу комісію в парламенті.
Денис не довіряє місцевим контролюючим правоохоронним органам,
адже,відповідно до дослідження центру,
в 2016-2017-му рокахМиколаївщина – у п’ятірці найкорумпованіших регіонів України,
а застаном правосуддя – взагалі остання.
Права людинивзагалі на останньому місці.
В минулому році в нас була серія підпалів автомобілів.
Зокрема автівок громадських діячів.
Були і резонансні вбивства.
Кількість корупційних скандалів на Миколаївщині -
це вже просто якийсь приклад біснуватих чиновників!
Співробітники "Миколаївського аеропорту"
не вірять у те, що винні будуть покарані.
За останні 7 років тут змінилися кілька директорів.
За цей час місцеві профспілки зібрали декілька томів звернень
до правоохоронців щодо незаконних дій керівництва
або їхніх кураторів від влади. Кажуть, усе,
чого вдавалося домогтися, – це порушення кримінальних справ,
які так і не дійшли до суду.